i love this book the lyrics because you
go one of the best songs i ever wrote
and then i was shocked when it was this
one
[Music]
what a song paul come on and i loved
that whole thing you were writing it and
you go she was just 17
never been a beauty queen
that was your first thought and yeah
john said to you no [ __ ] way right
we're not going to say never been a
beauty queen yeah we both looked at each
other and i knew
that he was going to say that and i was
like oops you know
this is not good that would have ruined
the song right paul it wasn't good it
just it was a rhyme but it wasn't good
you know it was funny years later i was
getting a star on the hollywood walk of
fame
and neil young was there
a good old nail a buddy you know and i
told him that story i said you know he's
never been a beauty queen
and he goes oh yeah great and then he
was playing that night it was a musical
thing you know a big uh benefit in la
and neil was playing on it and he did
the song and he used that line of course
[Music]
of course he did
he knows the only one to ever use that
line i think